Structs are a great way to
encapsulate values, but
we can take this one step further.
Let's modify the original syntax for
creating a struct.
Right now, we know that a struct
has the struct keyword, and
then we give the name of the struct,
followed by variables or
constants of any type, as many as we
want, and these are known as properties.
So I'm going to go ahead and
make a quick change to this.
Here's the difference.
With this syntax, we can see that
a struct can not only contain variables
and constants, but
instances of any type.
That means you can have structs that
contain structs that contain structs.
Essentially structs on
structs on structs.
Let's say we have this struct
representing a song, and
inside the struct we have property for
the song's title, its length, and
also properties for
the artist's first and last name.
So as we define a struct like this,
maybe we decide that we want to include
some more information about the artist,
like their age, and their hometown.
We can go ahead and
add these properties like so, but
this is beginning to look exactly like
the problem we had before structs.
We just have a bunch of variables and
constants,
and they're starting to
get a little disorganized.
And all this related information
could continue to grow and
get more unmanageable.
The best way to handle this is by
pulling the artist data out of the song
struct and creating a separate
struct that represents an artist.
There we go, now we have
an artist struct with first name,
last name, age, and home town.
And actually,
we could probably get rid of this
prefix because that would be redundant.
Now here's the powerful part.
Within the song struct, we can have our
own property, which itself is a struct.
So, let's do that now.
So now the song struct itself
contains an artist, and
this is really nice and elegant.
And as we'll see later,
expanding this to support
multiple artists is actually
a quite intuitive process as well.
So how would we access the properties
of a struct within a struct?
Let's go ahead and
see a code example to explain.
First, we'll create an artist struct.
How about country music
artist Garth Brooks?
We will use the syntax
we've seen before.
For the first name, we've given Garth.
For the last name, Brooks.
Age 53, and hometown is Tulsa, Oklahoma.
And this is according to Wikipedia when
I looked it up a couple of minutes ago.
And now that we have our artist struct,
creating a song struct
becomes pretty simple.
Let's create a struct for
his song Thunder Rolls.
So, we'll use the song
name Thunder Rolls,
which has a length of 3:42, and
we could represent this as a number,
but we're choosing to do it
as a string for right now.
And the last property that this
initializer needs is an artist, and
lo and behold, we have this artist
instance right here, called Garth.
So, we'll use Garth, and there we go.
We have an instance of a song struct.
Now, to access the information about
the artist contained within is
pretty straightforward and
uses the dot operator again.
So we'll start with thunderRolls.artist.
And if we go and
we look to see what it contains,
we can see all the properties
of the artists within.
And if we want to take this one step
further, we can use another dot
operator to access one of
the properties within artist,
like last name in this case,
which is Brooks.
So I'm sure you can start thinking
of some pretty complex and
cool relationship of
structs within structs.